The Amazon is the lungs of the earth, it
produces 20 percent of the oxygen on
our planet and is home to more
plant species than any other ecosystem. It
is also home to more than a million
indigenous people who have been living
there sustainably when for
generations their  natural heritage has
to be defended
[Music]
it is not the first time that the Amazon has been
devoured by flames it is true but
this year they have increased more than 80
percent compared to last year the
search for gold increases deforestation
and the mercury that  it is used pollutes the
water, the air and the food of
people and animals this
catastrophe responds to the
irresponsible policies promoted by
climate change deniers
we social democrats are also very
concerned about the fate of the
indigenous populations and their lands
we ask the Lord  Bolsonaro that complies
with the international obligations
of the Paris climate agreement and with the
clauses  The environmental ones that are
established in the Mercosur agreement and
I think that it is very appropriate in this
debate to remember an
Indo-American proverb only when the last
tree is dead when the last river
is poisoned the last fish is
caught will we realize that we
cannot eat the  money thank you very much
[Music]